all the leading actors and actresses all
the supporting actors and actresses 20
in total making it an all-white lineup
for this year's BAFTAs and coming just
four years after the Oscars so white
campaign forced the industry to promise
diversity would be a priority you'll be
bored of him in two years and will be
interesting and the controversy
continues with the directing category an
all-male lineup with the most notable
snub little woman's Greta Gerwig I think
it's important that we sort of stand out
and say we are very disappointed this is
not acceptable just to put it back sadly
we obviously need to in people's minds
that the diversity that we see you know
in Britain and on us you know also on
our screens throughout the year should
be reflected at the end of the year when
we come to celebrating that talent Bob
Clark founder of mama Youth Project
which works to bring diversity to the
media says he shocked by the nominations
this is just like a kick in the teeth it
really is you know why do should we
bother to continue and and for me we're
better done we've spoken to better
before you know we've had talks with
better to try and be more involved and
and it hasn't happened and then we have
this BAFTA 6,700 members all industry
professionals vote for the awards new
membership figures from 2017 show only
18 percent were from a minority ethnic
group and 43 percent were female its CEO
says today's lineup is disappointing we
after definitely need to do more we did
a scheme for women directors a couple of
years ago we need to do another one and
we need to go bigger because the talent
is there but the opportunities aren't
in terms of the films which were
nominated Joker starring Joaquin Phoenix
came out on top with 11 and has also
proved highly contentious with worries
its content incites violence was the
best thing I've ever seen in my whole
life Once Upon a Time in Hollywood a
love letter to old-school cinema follows
Joker with ten nods as does the Irishman
from Netflix which has virtually tripled
its nominations since last year thanks
to nods for the two popes and marriage
story but in terms of winners this
year's BAFTAs may well be eclipsed by
those films and the talent not nominated
at all Lucy Gossip Sky News